to listen to the
the hubris that's in her voice three
years ago talking to you Tim and the
response that I'm I'm your mother I tell
you when you're in time out when you're
not I tell you when you've been a good
boy or when you've been a bad boy I will
correct your behavior based on my
beliefs this is someone who never in her
entire life and it's not just her but
it's it's all these employees who sign
this letter they've never had to face
actual accountability at any point in
their entire lives until about five
minutes true and that woman that you
just talked about you know just had that
mindset she also had that mindset when
thinking about the president of the
United States When Donald Trump was
banned he was sitting in the Oval Office
and as Luke mentioned it is the most
important influential platform in the
world and that girl boss Vijaya which is
a fun name to say by the way I'm just
gonna throw that out there but she
banned the sitting president of the
United States for a lie